what do you do what's your claim to fame
I had no creator of this channel yeah
are you serious
yeah I mad yeah and he has to be is to
playlist on this channel too ah yeah
it's totally a thing I've been here
while he's been here people still don't
know who I am I'll post up people be
like this guy likewise who is this guy
like alright you just go back in the
archive
I'm sure bless your heart
hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Jerry and
I'm Matt from brown Pfeiffer brown here
today with us one of the stars of the
gallows now available on blu-ray and DVD
ya know so she's here with us today
we're gonna check out since you know
gals of horror movie no we're gonna
check out five creepy poltergeist
hauntings caught on tape about to go to
us poltergeist is believed to be a boast
or other supernatural being which is
supposedly responsible for physical
disturbances such as throwing around
objects and making a lot of noises in
this list we look at some cases where a
supposed poltergeist has been caught on
tape number five Donna
Abe responding this 33 year old from
Burleigh Lancashire UK claims that she's
being haunted by a poltergeist I won't
leave her alone she claims the
occurrences began in 2009 near the time
her brother passed away she said ever
since my brother died strange things
have occurred in every house I was
literally a freakin sweet keyboard
objects move around her house and some
objects even fly across the room why'd
she hear suspicious activity she grabs
her camera and starts to film
she has caught some pretty creepy
activity from cops moving on their own
to chandeliers violently swinging that
always said that she's me yeah stands at
home five times in order to escape
experience but she's had no luck she
claims to have grown increasingly more
violent and have even pinned her down to
her bed and also left scratches on her
back she believes it is her brother Paul
who died shortly before the disturbances
began she said giving the rocky
relationship with him I genuinely
believe his ghost is haunting me and not
just a house in which I live in
there have been arguments in the
comments about the authenticity of her
videos some pain she may be using wire
to move the objects but others believe
the haunting is real
she's currently got paranormal
investigators investigating the
spookiness check out some of her videos
for yourself and let me know what you
think I like
oh my gosh the surface isn't wet or
anything it's all dry so there's no
reason for it to be moving and it's
moving again oh this poltergeist this
creepy event began during the early
hours of the 1st of November 2012 but
forgets all occurred at our office in
Manchester UK wander offers what's most
some seriously scary occurrences took
place and they were caught on CCTV
when office workers arrived the next day
they'd found that office was a mess
there were chairs out of place documents
everywhere and misplaced
objects believing there may have been a
robbery they informed security the
security looked over CCTV and this is
what they found
at first chairs I see moving on their
own then door handles are see moving
furiously documents around the activity
continues for quite some time the
security were baffled and they were
quite creeped out they've put it down to
poltergeist activity stuff like that
Sally like the first thing I think of
now is that is he's on sorry stand up
dead
Jesus Christ's sake do something funny
in time like this
it makes a good point about like a lot
of ghosts being old and just seeing new
[ __ ] they're like holy [ __ ] these chairs
roll I have to hold them like
poltergeist apart by the name of Matt
Sorum of regional structure UK is
believed to be haunted by many different
ghosts the Pope has a reputation for
being haunted and there is a creepy
story about Rahab opposing see one of
the pub staff 400 years W chillin and
right is not so much as a club this was
found out after a hole was discovered in
the pub cellar which turned out to be a
well this is the place where the
children's drown it's now believed the
place is haunted by the children and
their mother on the 15th of August 2015
a member of staff at the pub by the name
of Nick arrived at one his remains
smash glasses all over the floor he
believes someone may have broke in so we
reviewed CCTV footage this is what
occurred in the pub up 143 a.m. many
glasses begin to randomly start falling
off the shelf it's quite creepy
some people claim you are able to see a
hand pushing the glasses from behind
others claim it might be a publicity
stunt in order to bring in more
customers yeah but some also do it as
poltergeist activity number 2 NQ ghost
hunter this man has had some extremely
creepy poltergeist activity going on in
this house for a long time
each time he hears something begins to
happen he quickly grabs his camera and
begins to record the creepy activity he
uploads all the creepy clips to his
youtube channel called NQ ghost hunter
the first video he uploaded was on
October 16 2010 he claims to have heard
strange noises and saw things move
around in his office building he grabbed
his camera and began to record after
this the poltergeist must have followed
him home because really creepy
occurrences began to start happening at
his home in Queensland Australia he has
caught many hours worth of poltergeist
footage he doesn't upload too frequently
but he did not blowed a few days ago
some believe his videos are fake but
others believe there is way too much
footage for it to be fake check out his
videos and let us know
you think make me a saint
numberland
manic violence comes in a mellow bird on
YouTube this man believes he has
captured some extremely creepy
poltergeist activity on tape believing
his house was haunted he began to record
every time you'd hear something strange
he has captured some bizarre and creepy
footage there have been certain footage
such as objects slightly moving there is
also other footage of his kitchen being
almost completely destroyed more violent
episode some people believe his videos
are fake others believe he has actually
caught a poltergeist on tape what do you
think
some argue that they can't be fake as
the realism to them is perfect check
them out and let us know what you think
thank you so much for watching if you
enjoyed the video then be sure to give
it a big thumbs up and don't forget to
subscribe Stan updated with our videos
goodbye
wait wait a minute that last person has
to have had multiple ghosts in there
because it was like doing the whole
kitchen
what then that begs the question like
what a ghost physics me yeah like I mean
you ready Waco's physics if you're bound
to just like well I had two hands in
life so I can only reach about this bar
like I don't know
Oh what is the entity you know which one
is the scariest for you like which one
got you guys the most I've seen the last
one the first one got me pretty bad at
which one that one yeah the one of the
one who was dumb enough to get the Ouija
board I need green eyes for it the first
woman where she was talking about how
she thinks it was her brother and how
they had a rocky relationship dude she's
throwing her brother under the bus he's
just gonna keep doing it I'm going to
have a much healthier relationship with
my brother mm-hmm cuz if he already
likes to kind of get back at you in real
life I can only imagine he's gonna do on
the other side oh yeah no he would like
steel online horn why would I be like
whoa whoa I he he like put some block on
my porn nice I gotta yeah he's just
adopted it through like that struggle
yeah it's really cool arm to struggle
yeah what if your opponent come on you
do struggling on something you know I
mean the night vision office campus the
one that got me I mean I don't know I
want to will I want to looks like an
awful work environment but that that's
what got that kind of brought tears to
my eyes that's what scared me the most
yeah well how they were like was
jiggling all the door handles yeah
because it's like it's so angry it's
silly yeah that's the one that scared me
and that one was just kind of robbed and
enough things are happening at the same
time where it's like oh this does just
kind of look natural because some of the
other ones I can't tell because it's you
know it's all camera and video so it's
like you can't eclis do anything to it
so it could be real but it could easily
be faked it just seems like these ghosts
are angry [ __ ] people
we oppose our guys sir Arbeit ray
like mischievous and so all ghosts are
bad not all ghosts is poltergeist is
like a classification it so poltergeist
means bad bad ghosts
yeah like the poltergeist like [ __ ] with
people that's sort of what they're known
for doing one time I walked into church
I was going there to pray by myself
um and then I and then I heard a voice
go hello like it sounded like a little
girl was I was loud it was Jesus I don't
think it was Jesus reading people from
the prison yeah so and then I said hello
like questioning it but no one responded
I looked around the whole church there
was no one there
seriously how close was the voice cuz
I've had a voice I've like heard a voice
felt pretty close in your ear or like no
I was like a little distance away I
wasn't in my ear it sounded like a
little black girl oh my god no
everywhere is not black nice I'm totally
racist against black people but all the
black subscribers like think it's
[ __ ] funny they know me the black
yeah you're really healthy but no I
think if I was a ghost I totally want to
go down the poltergeist route like if I
had an option like if I die and gods
like you could either be a ghost but you
got to talk to the ghost Academy or what
kind of ghost you want to be I would be
like I want to be a poltergeist I want
to just [ __ ] with [ __ ] yeah what's that
what's the point in being like a good
ghost well that week holy like you you
gave in somebody's house to haunt like
you don't [ __ ] with stuff but you will
move something like to a much more
convenient place who would you haunt you
I clean up their house that's like
somebody knocks over a glass of water
next to a computer I just be like oh my
god the water it's okay yes goes okay
you I see that as long as I'm scared of
them
yeah I'd be a rad ghost but who would
you haunt yeah okay I don't know if you
get to choose you know each get to pick
one one person ghosts get to choose
somebody
Brangelina oh I would love to haunt a
celebrity uh as you got like a bunch of
kids so you like [ __ ] rousing yeah
family I feel like I want to hunt like a
cool place then I don't know ever went
to hunt
Danny's hahahaha I'd hunt my high school
in Springfield Missouri it's like all
the kids that were like being bad
goldfish yeah I know right
like I'd be like this movie what they
called the gal oh yeah this was this
plant or was this know like that just
bring came to me in my head it was meant
to be meant to be me yeah game on no
sorry nerve oh my god this channel a
shadow brave - freakin channel yeah I
hunt a school and like all the kids
don't be like you bad little kids to the
teachers I'd like sabotage them ones
that were being good I'd like woosh only
answers all their tests I don't know I
think there's a lot of good you could do
yeah I don't think that would be
productive if you did the little dancers
from the coast hi anyway guys that's it
for today's episode if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects check out reasons to Gerry on
this channel like we were talking about
earlier I do exist reasons to cheer him
I am thing and you could check out
Pfeiffer brown in the movie Luke Gallows
now available on blu-ray and DVD
everywhere books are sold everywhere
bucks are sold and you follow you can
follow all of us on Facebook Instagram
Twitter vine well we have a periscope
you have a periscope like she doesn't
know repaired know like in a submarine
yeah we can see all your subscribers I
can see them from the sea
Oh hunting a submarine would be cool cuz
people can never escape
that's just so bad yeah we [ __ ] up you
hunt a submarine the Queen Mary is scary
enough and that's just a boat with like
an open deck so yeah if you like my wit
Han sorry I like Morman I would haunt a
haunted place
gyros of the ghosts in themselves no no
not a haunted house like what yeah like
my point no no no we're not like a real
haunted house just like a haunted house
we're like they're putting on an
attraction oh yeah and then you know
then it's like two levels yeah go like
knock [ __ ] over
I could you know like I don't know which
one is scarier the ghost works out okay
yeah I could like murder someone and
hang them by their other guts over those
thank God over the like a pole or
something yeah that'd be cool like that
we had him and then spell
Ryan was here in blind his blood from
his neck I'm going to check the ghost
rules I don't know if you would like
Creston to demon hood by that point well
according to the Academy as long as you
just progressed so you know like if you
keep up with your test scores you're
able to graduate into demonic hood okay
I guess yeah
nobody is quite as special as right oh
yeah I'm probably the least special
version on this couch now yeah yeah stop
what is it called self deprecation yeah
yeah cute thank you that's right thank
yous my what sort of thing that's my
claim to fame